[Música]
hoy 17 de febrero comienza el carnaval
de Río de Janeiro un patrimonio
inmaterial de la humanidad según la
UNESCO y el mayor festejo de Brasil los
nueve días de fiesta empiezan con la
coronación del Rey momo y los primeros
desfiles de las escuelas de samba que
ahora están protagonizadas por niños por
lo menos hoy la alcaldía reveló que la
ciudad puede obtener hasta 870 millones
de dólares por todo el carnaval pero más
allá de esto una de las preguntas de
fondo es que tanta representatividad
tiene la cultura afroacileña desde río
nos acompaña Carla López historiadora y
profesora de artes Carla Gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en France 24 y
si bien la Samba es un legado de
esclavos africanos que fueron llevados a
lo que hoy es Brasil y ese baile es el
centro del carnaval de Río de Janeiro
los brasileños no siempre han sido los
protagonistas
que tanto espacio tienen para expresar
sus narrativas culturales
agradezco la oportunidad
y en realidad
esa cultura
esa cultura afro negros mulatos mujeres
lgtbiq todos están dentro de esta
escuela de samba es la cultura de la
escuela de samba
la desigualdad es grande
pero en los últimos años
hemos intentado responder a este derecho
sobre hombres y mujeres negros
[Música]
como
como un gran homosexual
de la Bossa Nova del siglo 20
Madame satán la representatividad de los
negros y negras es grande pero la
visibilidad de su protagonismo ha sido
de los pocos que lo han contestado no
por la comunidad sino por la sociedad en
general y usted cree que hay apropiación
cultural por parte de mestizos y de los
turistas que van al Carnaval Y si su
respuesta es Sí cómo funciona esa
apropiación
la apropiación
es verdadera es real pero esta
apropiación
en los últimos años
ha sido un elemento que ha sido muy
discutido y estudiado
para que para estudiar De qué manera no
es correcta
algunas fantasías algunos disfraces
algunas decoraciones
para que represente la cultura del negro
y la negra brasileños
es necesario respetar y entender el
verdadero protagonismo de sus autores de
aquellos que construyeron y que
construyeron estos valores y respetarlos
y referenciarlos tenerlos en cuenta
tener una referencia hacer una
referencia
usted previamente nos explicaba que con
el paso de los años los brasileños han
podido revertir un poco esta apropiación
cultural a través de qué actos han
logrado volver a poner la cultura
brasileña en el centro del carnaval de
Río de Janeiro
la verdad
nosotros tenemos una nueva lectura
historiográfica y es muy importante esto
como los jóvenes y negros empezaron a
entrar en la academia el espacio
académico también
fue conquistado por la población negra
la historiografía oficial está siendo
totalmente reescrita Y en este sentido
esta revisión
está siendo apropiada por las escuelas
de samba que entendieron que ahora no es
una cuestión
de hacer como un exorcismo como los
negros y con los afros en Brasil
sino se trata del reconocimiento de su
presencia y de su valor y de su
protagonismo transformador en la
sociedad brasileña entonces la propia
revisión historiográfica académica ha
contribuido muchísimo para
lanzar este protagonismo para tenerlo en
el centro los hechos históricos hoy
negros y negras
han sido realmente los protagonistas de
la historia de este país vemos entonces
como la zamba no es tan solo un baile
sino también una plataforma para hacer
una revisión historiográfica como usted
la llama y Quiero preguntarle por algo
porque usted habla de la relación entre
estas expresiones culturales y los
pensamientos de la academia porque hay
un pensamiento específico abro brasileño
llamado El quilombo En qué consiste el
quilombo y cómo se expresa en el
carnaval de río
Entonces el kilombismo es justamente
traer la negritud
nuestra raíz es nuestros valores
valorizar esta negritud
es un pensamiento de resistencia es un
pensamiento de valorización de
reconocimiento de resignificación del
papel de los negros y las negras en la
sociedad brasileña Entonces el
kilombismo la cuestión
de los estudios de samba todas esas
corrientes de pensamiento tienen han
contribuido mucho en el cambio de este
Carnaval Y de las escuelas de samba de
Río de Janeiro y también de Sao Paulo
También tenemos que reconocer que este
movimiento es un movimiento de
resistencia lo que hablamos mucho aquí
en Río de Janeiro es que en la periferia
ha traído esta historia
ha conquistado este espacio de la
historia y tal como usted lo dice la
periferia de Río ha conquistado esta
parte de la historia en gran medida
porque la Samba comenzó en las favelas
desde principios de 1900 se comenzó a
practicar de una manera continua pero
ahora le quiero preguntar algo usted
habla del kilomismo como una resistencia
de las negritudes de Brasil cómo esos
actos de la resistencia de las
negritudes Y cómo el carnaval de Río y
la representación de las negritudes
brasileñas allí le hacen frente Por
ejemplo por ejemplo a la violencia
contra los brasileños que ya hemos visto
múltiples casos de afroadeños asesinados
solamente por su color de piel
es verdad es un proceso
el kilombismo todas estas corrientes de
pensamiento de valorización y de
resignificación ellas han contribuido
mucho
en el acompañamiento en el monitoreo de
todas estas estos comportamientos de la
de la población afroleña entonces hoy
tenemos en la sociedad brasileña todo un
grupo de varias corrientes del que lo
mismo y estudios pensamientos
intelectualidades interactuando
en la denuncia
y acompañando y reparando
en la justicia todos estos derechos que
se deben respetar de los ciudadanos
brasileños que los negros y las negras
no son unos ciudadanos de segunda
categoría son ciudadanos brasileños
y son patrimonio cultural históricos de
la sociedad brasileña Entonces tenemos
estos grupos
y es importante decir también que el
carnaval en las escuelas de sambayas
nacen en la periferia
son del suburbio carioca de Río de
Janeiro
y representa también la periferia de la
ciudad de Río de Janeiro Entonces
nosotros
en el momento de la Constitución
de estos nuevos grupos intelectuales
buscamos reparación en la justicia una
reparación en la justicia y una
ciudadanía reivindicada entonces de las
virtudes a través del carnaval de Río de
Janeiro Carla López Gracias por estar
con nosotros
os agradezco y les invito a todos a
acompañarnos en Estas fiestas